so we talked about merging but there's
another way that you can introduce your
changes into a branch and that's with
git rebase now I do want to have a
disclaimer here when you use git rebase
you are changing history but that might
be your preference and it might be what
your team chooses to do so let's talk
about the differences say we have two
branches working here this is the git
merge model and there's a B C and D on
one branch and EF on a separate branch
once we merge this branch into the other
branch the way that's gonna appear in
history is a B E C F D so it's when the
changes were made it's accurate but you
might want your history to be reflective
of a different nature you might want
your history to show when those changes
were introduced and make it more linear
that's when you would use git rebase
with rebase in the same situation
instead of merge it will show the
commits as ABCDEF in their logical order
like I said it's really a matter of
preference and what your team chooses to
do so just be sure to check with your
collaborators and make sure you know
which one you're expected to be working
with